les rues de fiera principale ville de
l'île sont encore calme depuis lundi la
grèce peut de nouveau accueillir les
touristes secteur crucial de l'économie
grecque représentant près d'un quart du
pib
avec son décor de carte postale
éclaboussé de soleil l'île de santorin
l'une des plus touristiques du pays
attend depuis trois mois de renouer avec
son effervescence
elle qui accueille normalement près de 3
millions de touristes chaque année
de la très belle santorin j'invite le
monde entier a visité la grèce en raison
de son hospitalité et sa sécurité en
matière d'hygiène l'île de santorin est
resté sans un seul 4 coronavirus pendant
la pandémie et à partir de maintenant
elle sera ouverte toute l'année pour
donner la possibilité à tous les
visiteurs de profiter de l'île et de ses
habitants sans torrent la magique vous
attend l'aéroport de santorin ne
rouvrira aux vols internationaux que le
1er juillet prochain
comme tous les aéroports régionaux de
grèce mais depuis lundi les voyageurs
d'une trentaine de pays ont été à
nouveau accueillis sur les aéroports de
thessalonique et athènes des voyageurs
provenant des régions du monde les plus
affectés par le comité sauf subiront des
tests systématiques et passeront nuit à
l'hôtel aux frais de l'état grec avant
une éventuelle quarantaine obligatoire
en cas de test positif
nous sommes ouverts nous sommes prêts
comme vous le voyez nos clients ils sont
tous en sécurité et nous attendons que
nos clients viennent ici avec la
meilleure humeur pour faire la fête mais
avec de la distance toujours avec de la
distance garder nous en vie et en
sécurité
si vous êtes les bienvenus à santorin
une distance qu'il faudra également
respecter pour admirer le très prisé
coucher de soleil sur l'île de santorin
à